ورد أن إيفان بيونسيه حصل على 24
مليون دولار لأدائه في
افتتاح هذا الفندق في دبي ، لكننا لا
نتحدث فقط عن حفلات الشركات المبهجة التي
تكتبها عن النجوم الكبيرة الذين
يلعبون حفلات الزفاف
وأعياد ميلاد بار ميتزفه التي تعرفونها تعطينا فكرة عن
السوق.  تكلفة استئجار
نجم البوب ​​لحفلتك القادمة
حسنًا ، سأعطيك مثالًا على سبيل المثال من العالم الحقيقي.
حفل زفاف أو حفلة خاصة تصل قيمتها
إلى حوالي ثلاثمائة ألف دولار
أه في الولايات المتحدة إذا كان يسافر إلى الخارج ، فإن
التكلفة تصل إلى حوالي مليون دولار ،
وأنت تعلم التحدث إلى وكلاء الحجز
والمحامين والفنانين أنفسهم ، لقد
شعرت بما هو السوق  يشبه
بيونسيه كما تعتقد أنه نوعًا ما على
مرتفعات الستراتوسفير ولكن يمكنك
الحصول على شخص مثل رود ستيوارت ليأتي
ويلعب حفلة شركة على سبيل المثال
لمليون وربع
الحقيقة المثيرة للاهتمام هي أن هذا كان
شيئًا كان  في الحقيقة ليس كل هذا
الشعبية والآن أه لكل من العملاء
والفنانين أنفسهم ، تراهم
يفعلون ذلك على أساس أكبر بكثير ، لقد
كان نوعًا من شيئين كبيرين حدث
أحدهما هو أنه في عصر
الموسيقى المتدفقة مقدار الإيرادات التي
انخفض الوصول إلى فنان بشكل كبير منذ عام
1999 والذي كان عندما بدأت Napster بشكل أساسي
عصر البث الذي كان بمثابة
وفاة القرص المضغوط الذي ترى
أن عائدات التسجيل قد انخفضت بنسبة
50 بالمائة وفي نفس الوقت
كان هناك هذا النمو الهائل في
الأساس  أرستقراطية جديدة منذ عام 2000
في الولايات المتحدة ،
تضاعف عدد المليارديرات بمقدار ثلاثة أضعاف عدد
ما يمكن أن تسميه نوعًا من مجرد
ثراء للغاية قد نما بشكل كبير أيضًا
في هذا العصر من عدم المساواة في الدخل
والنتيجة هي أن الأشخاص الذين قد يكونون قد
تفاخروا  في الماضي ، كانت مقاعد الصف الأمامي
في الحلبة تنفق الآن هذا النوع
من المال أو المزيد من المال
للحصول على اسم كبير ليأتي إلى الفناء
الخلفي أو غرفة المعيشة الخاصة بهم